[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to Merry
Christmas
I know a lot of you're expecting need to
have some sort of big explosion of joy
and cheer like you do all the other
years but a lot of people have been
saying that was kind of scary
and not really keeping in the Christmas
spirit so to keep me more relaxed I have
a chill pill patch so it'll keep you
completely under control so this year
things are going to be a bit more
traditional we have a fireplace
decorations we even have snow I have no
idea how that's possible
why hello Malcolm and Tamara that's a
cookies in a pot for us this holiday
season yes to relax us in this time this
isn't right huh this is Christmas you
should be able to celebrate it or
however you want to
sorry Tamara but I don't want to scare
the sweet people at home with my
disturbing obsession I want to be
relaxed soothing marketable that's what
people like yeah you weren't here the
previous years trust me this is for the
best this isn't right
[Music]
and seeing how we are having a much more
calm and subdued Christmas we're gonna
celebrate with a traditional calm
subdued Christmas special here's a
little ditty I like to call grandma got
run over by a reindeer mostly because
it's called grandma got run over by a
train
[Music]
it only fits that a Christmas song you
wish you never knew about will be giving
a Christmas special you wish you never
knew about since its release in 2000
grandma got run over by a reindeer has
gotten a lot of talk as being one of the
most memorably dumb holiday specials
ever produced and while it's not say
Christmas tree bad it is fascinating in
some of the choices it makes what are
those choices you may ask we'll get
ready for a cup of holiday awkwardness
this is grandma got run over by a
reindeer the film opens with the
narration by the singer of the song Elmo
Shropshire sounding it awful lot like
the opening of the fabulous secret
powers video it's the Christmas season a
time for telling colorful holiday
stories hi there I'm Adam Prince of
Eternia
of course he sings the song while we
watch our future road kill walked to her
enchanted hit and run and honestly I
know I'm gonna sound really weird and
perverted for saying it but grandma's
kind of hot look at the way they just
take away two lines change the head
maybe lose the glasses she's kind of a
bombshell I don't know what old women
the directors been looking at but are
they single
grandma got run over by a reindeer
alright and that's incredible as that
was it almost put an end to Christmas I
know he describes his grandma being
pummeled as incredible and then follows
it up with the actual bad news that it
almost ended Christmas I think this
guy's wait to accepting of violence to
the elderly it was December and everyone
in City bill was caught up in the chaos
of the holiday yeah that's right the
town is called City Vilnius it's not the
place where the Powerpuff Girls fight
crime I know it's a joke if you think
that's bad take a listen to what the
last name of our main characters are and
that's me Jake spanking heimer
Thank You heimer it sounds like a German
porno that takes place at an S&M dungeon
good the dog I am spanking hyah
well this is my lava but Vicky Nugent so
it looks like gramma owns a shop at even
Cracker Barrel would call excessive
where she reads to the kids while the
rest of her family takes care of the
customers but her grandson named Jake is
struggling with the idea that maybe
Santa Claus doesn't exist hmm adding to
your Christmas wish list uh I remember
when I had a random poster of a mule on
my wall it was right next to the globe
that no kid has ever owned yet for some
reason keeps popping up in kids room
cliche tell her mom Santa Claus is real
well there is no easy answer
historically there was a Saint Nick who
with a loving heart filled children's
shoes with gifts of all sorts so Santa
today represents the true meaning of
Christmas giving to others see that's
funny because um I'm pretty sure you
want to get across that Santa exists in
this world
see how it's called grandma got run over
by a reindeer and you literally just -
this kids dreams by bringing up the
Saint Nick stuff
we're four fucking minutes in and
already you have no idea what your
mythologies is kind of shatters the
illusion doesn't it I don't think other
stories would hold up as well if they
were as inconsistent with their world
and so three earrings were given to the
elves who were kooky mecca's led by Will
Ferrell seven to the dwarves poor miners
best known for their harmonizing and the
rest were given to I don't know there's
no easy answer but there's a wizard who
works at Hogwarts in a little person who
lives with the Lannisters now if you'll
excuse me I'm off to eat lunch hmm
that's good now carry him Santa Claus
real and what your mother said hey who
wants to put up a tree yeah distract
from his possibly shattered reality if
you're looking at the new inflatable
Christmas tree manufactured by the
CityVille own all corporation is the top
of a tree looking a little phallic to
anyone else it just hurts we had to chop
our trees down by hand never forget the
time I had to use a beaver for a
chainsaw last time you told it it was a
woodpecker so let me get this straight
a penis shaped tree is reminding you of
the time where you confused a beaver for
a pecker
this all gonna be a lot more interesting
if you included this stuff in it the
next day a shadowy man approaches even
though lighting lives there's no reason
he should be like that who's the CEO of
onal corp presumably a division of
Google and Disney grandma says you own
everything
well not yet but that's why I want to
speak to your grandma
I wanna buy her right now grandma
elfin himer is reading to the kids I
heard about that say you wouldn't happen
to have an extra elf costume I could
wear
I always pointlessly dress like strange
characters when conducting business
deals you should see what I wore when I
tried to get the rights to Fifty Shades
of Grey
and did
you'd be selling to the biggest and the
best do you know why my company controls
every mall and sidewalk Santa because
it's the past voice of a ninja turtle I
know firsthand that you can market
anything your store sits on the perfect
place to build a crown jewel of my
empire gifts delivered on Christmas Eve
by our new sleigh mobile I could also
make our obvious commentary stronger by
putting Kirk Cameron on top of it Jake
do you think I should sell the store are
you kidding I love this place Oh what
happened to his eyes there I love this
place Jesus Christ that's fucking scary
it looks like the mask of movie serial
killer would wear
[Music]
well another family member named cousin
Mel played by Michelle Lee thanks
grandma is crazy for not selling grandma
if this store were mine
I'd sell it cousin Mel this store will
never be yours oh yeah I don't know if
that was really oh yeah
worthy think it was more than I
acknowledged you just said something
worthy the way I see it you can divide
the world into two groups people who
like fruitcake and all the rest of it
wait fruitcake what does looking
fruitcake have to do with any really
this is warranting of a song
grandma's killer fruit okay you're so
obviously not interested in what your
characters are going through that you
gave a song to a fucking fruitcake this
is like that whose lies in any way game
where you have to make up a song out of
a random word you just said so that my
grandmother made fruitcake so what'd you
do today Frank
well I animated the state of Kentucky
belching living the dream so grandma
gets ready to take her treats to the
Community Services Building presumably
trying to get on the cover of mother
Theresa weekly as the song quite
obnoxiously sings what they're already
verbally telling us she'd been drinking
too much egg you've been drinking too
much eggnog
and we begged her not to raise don't go
but she forgot her medication door and
do the snow like fast ha I don't like
this words we also dictate its dictates
makes hell are you doing I'm singing
what you are say why it's like putting
the atom less seam in the dark night
there's no reason for it well trying to
make already hot hoping to accomplish
talking to you
as expected senator comes a knocking on
granny's temple and conser literally out
cold and that's the special kids her
funeral was three days later no no if
only it was that simple
no those special keeps going as jake
tries to tell everybody what he saw was
here and nail honey you must have had a
bad dream in case you haven't noticed
Frank your son suffers from a dreaded
affliction what affliction first Santa
Claus is real syndrome he's got all the
symptoms writing mr sadk ok guys while
you're having this friendly little chat
there is an old lady face down in the
snow freezing to death I don't think the
boy should be as comfortably calm as he
is but strangely enough when they open
the door grandma
appears to be gone that's right officer
missing hit by Santa's sleigh yes we've
been drinking eggnog
Fairey son impossible right here in the
manual there's no such thing as Santa
Claus it's too we got a cold 1225 Santa
Claus is real syndrome family dispute
Wow
Saturday morning version of Fargo it's a
lot more different than I thought it
would be so the special could be saved
with Grandma in the wood chipper what
appears to be an impression of a person
in the snow up there but how do we know
what's grandma my god I'll ransom note
from Santa says if you want to see
grandma alive you'll hand over all the
cookies I'd like to know where grandma
is good point we can work the Santa
angle later Peter can't looking for the
old Brad wait a minute did she just say
looking for the old broad looking for
the old Brad this somehow I get the
feeling the original song didn't have
such choice lyrics the old broad got run
over by a reindeer lousy bitch was blind
as a one-eyed whore fuck what so after
literally months go by yeah this is sort
of a Christmas and a half special they
declare grandma officially dead and walk
around the house and funeral clothes
clearly with the sister going through
something as the business starts to fade
without her presence so cousin Mel tries
to sell the store but see Elio tells her
that she can't without grandpa Geppetto
signature so she takes him out and tries
to force him to sign it's right here in
these papers all you have to do is sign
saying no sign sure so
I'd rather say grandma's bending Wow
fucking Wow I thought the fruitcake
transition was bad but that is by far
the worst segue to a song ever conceived
I mean amazing
you put no thought or effort into that
transition whatsoever you just jumped
without a parachute and didn't care at
all what the consequences would be oh
right they just son did you say it's
been one week since you look to be
cocked your head to the side said I'm
angry five days since you lied to me
saying get that together come back and
see me no I said son oh good you know I
got a music video crew ready to go
lights camera the whole thing I just
well I didn't say that well I feel silly
oh and extra points for including a shot
of her undies flying off because lord
knows after the old broad line we just
had to level out with something more
family-friendly no I need a break from
weird sexualized grannies I'm gonna go
look at some proper Christmas porn ooh
gingka balls all the way and
Schwarzenegger is in it
[Applause]
[Music]
so grandpa signs the papers after
hearing his dumbass song which comes to
the dismay of Jake I'm going over to see
Austin bucks and sells this dump for
millions millions this place was worth
millions the whole time
grandpa how could you do that
what do you mean how could he do that
fucking Millions you little idiot I've
gotta stop why think of all the people
you can help think of all the hungry you
can feed think of all the charities you
could give to are you saying you'd
rather read stories to one two three
three kids and serve one two three four
five six customers are supposed to help
thousands and thousands of people not go
to bed hungry tonight
I think grandma's actually fucking
insane but nevertheless we gotta keep
her tradition alive and well as Jake
tries to talk to Mel's lawyer please
don't buy grandma's store too late kid
cousin Mel's attorney I am slime you
said it not me
yes sorry Jake
did they really think people would be
laughing so hard at that line they
actually needed a pause for it did they
work hours on that line did they think
people would just be in an uproar over
the amount of laughter that they were
producing and you said it not me oh
sorry the plus sign was broken so of all
people see Elio thinks up the most
obvious thing that the kid can do if you
really believe grandma was run over by
Santa's reindeer then find him he should
know where grandma is okay just a mere
nine months later he's finally doing
what he should have been doing from Dave
fucking was to Santa Claus Santa Claus
is real calm he writes an email to Santa
which now that I think about it how old
can the grown-up version of this kid
telling the story be if there's goddamn
email in it and Santa eventually gets it
sure enough it turns out Santa had
grandma the whole time and when I say
had I don't mean in that way I think I
mean she claims she has amnesia but were
there no other hospitals to take her to
no police stations
his only recourse was to whisk her off
all the way to the fucking North Pole
hell he knows who everyone in the world
is so couldn't he through deduction
figure out where she lives
is that like she was that far away from
the house I mean by god nine fucking
months of signs and milk cartons and
Santa never came across any of that even
the signs I could kind of understand but
the milk cartons the fucking milk
cartons milk and cookies hello kind of
his thing I think he would notice
damn car north Oh gramma spankin heimer
nope never matter but you might ask one
of those short-sellers classic case of
amnesia can't remember a thing
wait is it mere DeSantis sound Jewish if
I could make just one stinking person
who understands the holidays this race
is so many puzzling questions this is
like the Christmas Da Vinci Code so one
of the elves goes to tell Jake that his
grandma is okay you're an elf the
genuine article
[Music]
well that was a confusing parody should
we throw it some random Wizard of Oz
references while we're at it would you
like to find your grandma then follow me
so all the who's and who the fuck
relayed this bill gather around to see
the reunion of Jake and his grandma
but grandma still has amnesia it's me
Jake nope nothin sure her Tweety Bird
that'll jog her memory so even though
she still doesn't remember she agrees to
go with Jake and Santa to stop the store
from being sold but cousin Mel sees
grandma decides to kidnap her I guess
she's just kind of used to it after
being held hostage for nine months
grandma we couldn't find her anywhere
this of course leads to one logical
conclusion since grandma is nowhere to
be found
and the man in the red suit here
admitted he ran over her I demand that
you have Santa arrested for the
disappearance of grandma uh I don't
think that would be the headline the
real headline would be holy shit Santa
Claus is real scientist study flying
reindeer for advanced warfare meanwhile
our two villains hold on to a
surprisingly accepting of her kidnapping
grandma okay just because she has
amnesia doesn't mean she'll do anything
an older person wouldn't just stay
locked up in a cabin with no questions
asked unless you're in this cabin next
door but I just don't ask questions with
that guy Santa Claus must be worth a
fortune your share as grandpa's
financial adviser is
[Music]
well looks like the animators took
another taupe break and accidentally
sent the wrong footage to the studio
again
are there any song sequences that don't
look like bad flash animation ecards
could you just see someone sending this
to a co-worker I'm at the courthouse
where the sensational Santa Claus trial
is reaching its climax district attorney
Hartung is making his impassioned
summation okay hard tongue really
fucking hard ton for fuck's sake are
there any names in this world that
aren't fitting character traits given by
two-year-olds your honor black judge
join the crazy pupil the evidence proves
Santa Claus is responsible for grandma's
disappearance
well that doesn't date this at all care
to throw in to Borat joke while you're
at it but Jake finds his grandma Joe
loves her memory and brings her to the
jury of Dilbert caricatures to explain
their case if you and the jury would
taste this fruitcake this one was made
by Grandma using her special ingredients
taste it and then compare it to the
pieces of cake found at the scene of the
alleged crime I think we'll find a
difference between the two now I may be
an old-fashioned lawyer child but I do
say if the cake tastes like shit you
must acquit
oh we represent all right oh okay how
about this one um smokey and I got a
save for a special obviously made for
seven-year-old there is a lot of core
talk in the last five minutes of this
film this is a note Santa left that the
accident Saints sleigh hit killer
negligence state's evidence number 12 to
the charge of leaving the scene of an
accident dusted for fingerprints do they
honestly think they have to represent
the justice system as properly as
possible are people really going to
question the legal ramifications of
Grandma got fucking run over by a
reindeer rights to the store and I'm
behind this evil trial and I hate the
goody-goody feelings of Christmas Wow
saying the word and really seems to be
the ultimate truth serum and and they've
got a sixth change when I was 20 and and
that responsible for killing JFK and and
I like shiza with puppies while shopping
candy corn up my anus and licking a
lollipop made out of the flavored tears
of orphaned children
stop arrest this woman for obstructing
justice and almost ruining Christmas
that's what you get for being selfish
and stupid there's more to life than a
little money you know don't you know
that and just a book in the story I
guess they decide to run over the old
broad once again
[Music]
so that was grandma got run over by a
reindeer it's about as good as the song
it's totally pointless and half-assed
which is strange seeing how the director
has done some other good holiday stuff
in the past but I will say it's
something kind of comical to just how a
forced it all is you just can't believe
how lazy the segways are what cutouts
the characters remain and how utterly
unnecessary everything in this special
is I suppose in that sense it is kind of
worth seeing
just to witness how uninspired a
commercial knockoff of an already pretty
annoying song can be but if you're
looking for something that truly when
you over this holiday Monday recommend
Kahlua enigmatic I hope you enjoyed that
and I'm so sorry I couldn't have my
traditional over-the-top reaction to
Christmas this year
but like every element of our media says
it should be calm relaxing soothing just
a little bit silly just like grandma got
run over by a reindeer so from all of us
to you I wish you a very Merry crew
Creek this isn't right you shouldn't
refresh yourself during the holidays you
don't know what you're doing you should
be able to express yourself however you
want hair must stop putting your freak
what have you done Malcolm no one should
have to hold back their feelings on
Christmas Christmas is about love beauty
and the acceptance of your
[Music]
I'm full of Christmas semen I don't know
what it is but it's hot it's like F in
sarcasm inside an oatmeal cookie shot
and when I put my Santa hat on it's a
needle full of Christmas kaliya coating
my house in Frisian Disney trademark
intellectual property cause it's no wig
shopping Christmas setting the lights of
my fuckin house a fuckin crazy about
Christmas
fucking Christmas
ladies and gentlemen Jesus Christ of the
electric guitar
[Applause]
you wanted a magic knight rayearth good
I'll buy all things are the green
accumulating thousands of dental cannot
be taught ruin my life
making it the best Christmas yet don't
play those Christmas carols until my
gears will flee with Christmas cheer
it'll scare the shit out of you what
it's only getting bigger every year does
it snow we love shopping
let's get the shit out of you cousin
fucking batshit crazy about Christmas
but Reagan hot chocolates and my skin is
random
and the deals and appeals and appeals
if the steals embassy
getting guys feeling wires I'm inspired
I'm a buyer right
are you
I want to smash it open - it's different
golden a surgeon for a French Christmas
goal and then drink his blood type
please control
don't ever fucking do that again I'm
sorry but he has a sickness they're
gonna be cured by repression and
tranquilizers
yes fucking scary it's snowing yeah I
love shopping and I farfel farfel farfel
King loved Christmas enough to build
tranquilizer immunity I must be fucking
batshit way to Missy What did he say
I'll kill anyone not celebrating with me
your assistant defeating my insanity
does a snow job big so what the star
atop the tree you find the unlucky TV
work going
boy that did feel good thanks so much
you guys
hey cuz it's no shit out of you crazy
about Christmas chocolates and my skin
is red mr. solid
you
[Music]
better get looking for the old Brad
hey guys dog walker here did you like
that song at the end of course you
Dickens it's Christmas and Christmas is
awesome and that song was written by
routs gallon and it is available for
download like we say in the song so if
you want to download that here's the
link today you can go check it out all
that good stuff
second December 7 vets this upcoming
weekend my brother and I are gonna be
appearing at the Barnes & Noble in Oak
Brook Mall uh you probably recognize her
that's the one where Dante Bosco beats
the shit out of me and the top 11 Avatar
episodes and we don't have fun stuff
there before and this year we are doing
a tribute to Christmas specials and this
is very much an interactive thing where
we all just kind of get together and
talk about Christmas specials then one
of the best things about Christmas so we
all just come together and sort of
interactive and we talk about it you
talk about your your favorite ones worse
once all sorts of stuff like that and
afterwards we're going to be doing a
signing like prints and merchandise all
sorts of good stuff and if you have a
question to ask or something we'll be
there for that too so uh drop them by
and talk Christmas with us and finally
last thing we are going to be doing a
charity auction soon with a bunch of
props and stuff that we've had over the
years we haven't been one in a while and
this is gonna be for charity we've done
before here's the link to that it's for
children who have cancer and this is a
very special camp that set up for them
and it's a wonderful cause and we
visited there and it's just a phenomenal
place so we will keep you we will keep
you updated on what the props are and
costumes is done we have like the Dante
Basco
outfit signed his Zuko outfit we have
like one of the nostalgia critic suits
the one that I like I rolled around it
and food fight and stuff like that next
match critic hat so yeah all sorts of
stuff is gonna go up for auction and I'm
just bringing it up now even though I
haven't officially put on eBay yep I'm
just pulling up now because guys you
know it's that time of the year where
you really want to give to those less
fortunate and we can just tell you this
is a good cause so um yeah that's about
it guys hope Christmas is shaping up
great for you and we'll see you in
December with more great stuff on the
way so see you later